all right daivam ask your question we've
looked at this cares act and we know
that the checks was supposed to be
coming and all this other stuff where do
you think they're gonna continue the
checks or is this a one and done well I
don't have an idea I mean who knows what
you're predicting Washington well you
won't make me laugh what but yeah but
I'm predicting what those people are
gonna do they wanted to blow windmills
in the stimulus package I predict what
those people gonna do they're crazier
and a beam but the I dunno no I I hope
there's not another one because I mean
we were already 19 trillion dollars in
debt now we're 21 trillion dollars in
debt that's right and I I'm thankful
that some of you were getting a 1200
I'll check each and a $500 per kid check
and all this stuff and but truthfully if
two thousand dollars changes your life
you were already struggling honey you
already had other issues in your income
or your budget or your spending or
something I mean think about $2,000
changes your life it means you're
mathematically don't have much of a life
ratio-wise I mean because you know if
it's 10% of your world it means you make
twenty thousand dollars a year which
means you make one third of the national
average of a household income so you're
struggling already yeah you're the
poverty level already if it changes your
life so it'll help you and I'm glad
you're getting the help I'm not mad
about anything but this idea that
somehow you're gonna be okay because the
government sends you $1,200 truthfully
honey you're gonna be okay because of
you
if you keep a clear head and good
critical thinking skills and you know
you go pick up a job because you lost
one and you go pick up two jobs because
you lost one you go pick up three jobs
because you lost one and suddenly I'm
delivering for Amazon during the day and
pizzas at night and blowing leaves on
the weekend because rich people are
scared of leaves you know and I'm doing
whatever it takes right
you can social distance your but from
some leaves right so I mean there's all
kinds of things you can do to create an
income and that's gonna be a whole lot
more important than 1200 hours yeah no
you're absolutely right from an ongoing
measure and I just I addressed that on
my show today you think we're gonna get
another one
I don't I do not I I don't know if the
American people have a political stomach
for this again though they were so
afraid of everything that they got
chased into their homes and they were so
afraid of anything that they thought if
Congress didn't pass something that we
were all going to die because they keep
thinking Washington's gonna fix their
lives for years they thought that is
until I mean what happens in your house
is a lot more important what happens in
the White House that's right and so you
know there's not anything gonna come out
of DC that's gonna help you long term I
mean you get some small helps out of it
but I mean that if you say thirty years
from now I'm a success it will not be
because of a bill that was passed you
know that's just it will be because of
you got up left the cave kill something
and drug it home that's so it works in
the real world and so but we've been
trained by our obsession with politics
and politicians that they're gonna
somehow provide for us mm-hmm and so
it's nice that they try and some of them
actually have a good heart I guess so
few of them it's hard to imagine but
truthfully most of its about them it is
it really is and it's almost like they
see us as puppets and they know how to
pull the strings I can see another
stimulus package becoming square sin or
into the upcoming election I can see
that that that that you know that that
word being thrown around as if it's
going to save the day and I just it were
well I think if you wanted to ensure
that Trump is not re-elected what you'd
want to keep the economy shut down as
long as possible because the economy you
know the more it's going to fail the
harder it's gonna be for him to be
elected that's what it's gotten down to
and so I'm not saying there's evil
forces at work here I don't know any
idea but it does feel a little bit like
trading places where it ends the dollar
over he's you know bets him that and at
the end he has the dollar but I know
Mortimer right it makes them a they make
this dollar bet on the guy's life yeah
you know and so that that's what's going
on I'm not and I'm not saying they're
doing this somebody's doing this to get
Trump out of all
that's not the point but if you can
extend it another week by Annie it gives
that much more damage it's gonna have an
impact on him and and on the other hand
if everybody dies because of the corona
virus or something then then he won't be
elected either so he's got to manage the
tension between the two for his own
political aspirations and so it's it's
very interesting to see what they can
agree on up there but at the end of the
day you can't control any that all you
can controls you throw in all I can
control is me though and I'm going to
control my attitude and I'm going to try
and control my money that I have
actually in my hands and I'm gonna
control my opportunities that are in
front of me by not succumbing to panic
and hysteria do